hallo und willkommen zu ZDF heute live
erst war es ein Ballon dann folgten drei
weitere Verdächtige unbekannte
Flugobjekte die das US-Militär über
Nordamerika abgeschossen hat bei den
Ballon weiß man dass er aus China kam zu
spionagezwecken sagen die USA Peking
dementiert und sagt es war ein
Wetterballon der sich verirrt habe das
wiederum halten Experten für wenig
glaubhaft aber auch China wird andersrum
den USA Spionage vor allein im letzten
Jahr hätte es mehr als 10 Überflüge
gegeben von Balance aus den USA über
China und auch das sei nicht erlaubt
gewesen was hat das alles zu bedeuten
was könnte Chinas Spionage Ziel jetzt in
diesem Fall gewesen sein und warum
werden dafür im 21 Jahrhundert überhaupt
noch Balance verwendet klingt ja so ein
bisschen aus der Zeit gefallen diese und
weitere Fragen besprechen wir heute mit
dem Militärexperten und oberste Ralf
Thiele und unsere Reporterin in
Washington mit Heike slanski eure Fragen
und Kommentare wie immer gerne an uns
per Mail oder über unsere Social Media
Kanäle und zuerst bringt uns Thomas ja
auf den aktuellen Stand der Dinge
da war was in der Luft tagelang schwebte
dieser Ballon über den USA dann Abschuss
auf Befehl von US-Präsident beiden
Geschehen vor zehn Tagen vor der Küste
sauf carolinaers es folgt vergangenen
Freitag vor der Küste Alaskas bei Bruno
Bay ein silbergraues Objekt groß wie ein
Kleinwagen am Samstag ein zylindrischer
Körper über den kanadischen Yukon beide
so heißt es auch Ballons und am Sonntag
etwas über den Julian See in sechs
Kilometern Höhe eine Gefahr für die
Luftfahrt alle vier Objekte abgeschossen
das erste kommt aus China die anderen
drei unklar aus den USA heißt es heute
die drei neuen Objekte hätten wohl nicht
chinesischer Spionage gedient der erste
der sicher chinesische Ballon dagegen
schon Fotos von der Bergung zeigen eine
Art antennenvorrichtung ein Wetterballon
sagt Peking einer zum Ausspähen sagt
Washington wir konnten ermitteln dass
China ein Spionageprogramm betreibt mit
hochfliegenden Ballons erhitzt
mittlerweile die Tonlage aus Peking seit
Mai letzten Jahres haben die USA viele
Balance losgeschickt sie haben die Erde
ständig umkreist und sind illegal auch
über den Luftraum Chinas geflogen mehr
als 10 mal ohne Erlaubnis alles falsch
sagen die USA und China lehnt ein
Gespräch mit dem Pentagon ab die
ballonaffäre sie ist zum Streit zwischen
Großmächten geworden da ist
sprichwörtlich was in der Luft
fangen wir nach bei Heikes lanski in
Washington das Thema hat heute auch den
US Senat beschäftigt was ist denn dabei
herausgekommen
ja das ist richtig der die us-senatorin
wurden heute informiert allerdings
hinter verschlossenen Türen Türen es
gilt die höchste Geheimhaltungsstufe
nichtsdestotrotz haben sie sich im
Anschluss den Medien geäußert und da
hängt es einfach davon ab welcher mal
Partei man zugehört die demokratischen
Senatoren betonen immer wieder dass Joe
Biden der Präsident alles richtig
gemacht hätte die Sicherheit sei nicht
in Gefahr von diesem Land und das
Gegenteil sagen die Republikaner sie
sind der Ansicht dass der Präsident zu
schmale lippig ist dass er sich dem Volk
erklären müsste weil doch über diese
Gefahr öffentlich gesprochen werden
müsste sei es eine
Spionageaffäre zwischen China und
Amerika oder aber wenn der zivile
Luftraum in Gefahr ist und
möglicherweise Maschinen deshalb
tangiert werden könnten insofern sind
die Republikaner der Ansicht und
versuchen den Präsidenten zu treiben
dass er sich öffentlich erklären sollte
einige Fragen sind ja noch offen du
hattest mir das auch im Vorgespräch
schon gesagt also unter anderem stellt
man sich ja auch in den USA die Frage
inwieweit vielleicht diese vier
Flugkörper miteinander irgendwie in
Zusammenhang stehen könnten ist dazu
heute irgendwie weiteres nach außen
gedrungen
ja also es ist nach wie vor nicht sehr
klar was merkwürdig ist ist dass es
heute hieß dass die drei weiteren
Abschüsse jetzt vergangenes Wochenende
angeblich nichts mit dem chinesischen
mit dem ersten großen Ballon zu tun
hätten woher man das weiß das ist uns
nicht gesagt worden denn Fakt ist dass
die abgeschossenen Trümmer die flugteile
die man vielleicht noch findet in einem
schwierigen Gebiet sind manche im Wasser
in diesem Legion der sehr tief ist das
andere in den Rocky Mountains von Kanada
also auch schwer zu finden und in Alaska
wo - 40 Grad herrschen im Moment das
sind schwierige Bedingungen überhaupt
irgendetwas zu finden und dann darüber
Auskunft geben zu können des Weiteren
ist es ja auch merkwürdig dass ich
niemand zu diesen Objekten bekennt also
keine private Firma die vielleicht
irgendein versucht gestartet hätte oder
ein anderes Land also auch insofern
tappen die wir da weiterhin im Dunkeln
wenngleich heute der Sprecher des
Sicherheitsrates sagte im Kreise von
Journalisten dass er glaube dass diese
drei weiteren Objekte die am Wochenende
abgeschossen worden sind nichts mit dem
chinesischen
spionageballon wie es hier in Amerika
heißt der vor gut einer Woche
untergeholt wurde vom Himmel zu tun
hätten China behauptet ja dass die USA
ihrerseits auch mehrere Balance im
vergangenen Jahr eben über China haben
fliegen lassen auch das sei nicht
angemeldet oder erlaubt gewesen
Washington wiederum dementiert das wie
glaubhaft ist jetzt wiederum dieses
Dementi
ja das ist natürlich schwer für uns zu
sagen fakt ist dass die Amerikaner das
vehement dementieren ich glaube man kann
bestimmt sagen dass Länder gegenseitig
spionieren und jeder macht es ebenso gut
erkannt jetzt gibt es halt diesen Ballon
das ist sicher ein Fehler gewesen von
den Chinesen dass er ertappt wurde auch
wenn sie behaupten es sei ein
Wetterballon gewesen da sprechen ganz
viele Fakten dagegen
insofern kann ich hier nur wiedergeben
was uns offizielle Sprecher von Behörden
halt mitteilen ja ich kann an der Stelle
vielleicht gerade noch hinzufügen dass
es durchaus Zeitungsartikel gibt die
sich auch mit diesem Thema beschäftigt
haben und in denen davon die Rede ist
das auch gerade die USA Ihr Budget was
eben diese Sorte von flughörnern angeht
auch für das eigene Militär auch zu
überwachungs und
nachrichtendienstlichen Zwecken durchaus
auch ausgebaut haben in den letzten
Jahren also das ist durchaus mit
Vorsicht zu genießen aber klar gehörte
zu Spionage auch dazu dass man da nicht
immer so die Wahrheit erzählt trotzdem
auch noch mal die Frage wie sehr
beunruhigt ist
entschuldigung ich wollte nur sagen es
ist halt die Frage was ein Ballon oder
war es ein Satellit also das Satelliten
um die Erde schweben und überall gucken
was sie kriegen können das ist glaube
ich allgemein bekannt dass es jetzt sich
um einen Ballon handelt der halt viel
tiefer fliegen kann und deswegen
vielleicht genauere Erkenntnisse über
irgendein wichtiges Ziel oder eine
Infrastruktur oder vielleicht ähm
militärische Anlage bekommen kann das
ist halt hier das neue ja klar über den
militärischen Sinn oder Unsinn natürlich
auch die Frage ja das stellt sich
natürlich für die Amerikaner die Frage
haben die Chinesen jetzt eine Technik
entwickelt die vielleicht ihrer voraus
ist oder eben nicht wie gesagt das dass
sie selber zehn Ballons hätten das
bestreiten die Amerikaner nach wie vor
also wir werden über die
Sinnhaftigkeit dieser Balance gleich
auch noch mit dem Experten mit Herrn
Thiele ausführlich sprechen letzte Frage
an dich wie sehr beunruhigt dieses Thema
die amerikanische Öffentlichkeit wie
sehr wird es auch in den Medien wieder
gespielt ist eine größere Besorgnis
jetzt doch zu beobachten
absolut das ist nach wie vor hier eines
der Top-Themen es wird jeden Tag darüber
berichtet weil ja auch nach wie vor ganz
viele Fragen offen sind und es
beunruhigt auch viele Leute weil wenn es
sich hier um Spionage handelt ist die
Frage warum wieso weshalb und mit
welchen Konsequenzen man zu rechnen hat
und wenn es nur
Flugkörper waren die möglicherweise die
zivile Luftfahrt stören könnten ist es
auch nicht gerade beruhigend insofern
ist es hier nach wie vor ein großes
Thema die Einschätzungen unserer
Kollegin Heikes Lanzke aus Washington
ganz lieben Dank danke schön
ja und übrigens kamen was die bislang
unbekannten drei Flugobjekte angeht
heute auf Fragen auf nach einer etwaigen
Außerirdischen Herkunft bzw gestern
wurden die auch schon bestellt und dazu
wollte dass USA die Partner bzw die US
offiziellen noch nichts sagen heute
klang das dann so
ich denke nicht dass sich die Amerikaner
über Aliens Gedanken machen müssen Punkt
ich denke nicht dass dazu noch was
gesagt werden muss
okay das war John Kirby kurz und knackig
also offenbar keine Aliens was das
angeht sagte schon Kirby aber ein
weiterer Gast ist uns zugeschaltet der
militär-experte und oberste die Ralf
Thiele einen schönen guten Abend hallo
noch einen schönen guten Abend Herr
Thiele sie sagen dass die Chinesen zum
gegenwärtigen Zeitpunkt ihre Spionage
über den USA verstärken das ergibt
durchaus Sinn denn in den USA war in den
letzten Tagen militärisch logistisch
einiges los können Sie das mal ein
bisschen genauer ausführen was meinen
Sie damit
de facto war das ja weltweit die
Amerikaner operieren ja in der ganzen
Welt haben überall auf jedem Erdteil
ihre Kommandos kommunizieren miteinander
und wenn man mal in heutige Krieg
Führung hineinschaut da geht es hier
darum andere aus zu manövrieren
schneller zu sein schneller Daten
auszuarbeiten auszuwerten und dann
wieder ein Handlung zu übersetzen und
zudem Zweck war tatsächlich eben vor
zwei Wochen eine Woche lang ein
weltweites Experiment mit Schwerpunkt in
Nordamerika wo es darum ging wie man
amerikanische Führungssysteme gestützt
mit künstliche Intelligenz und neuen
Verschlüsselungstechnologien fitter
besser machen kann und das war natürlich
ein goldener Zeitpunkt Chinesen da mal
hineinzuschauen was ist das eigentlich
wie kann man das erkennen was wir
Technologien benutzen sie dabei können
wir da ein paar Daten sammeln und mal
auswerten wie man das dann knacken kann
also das war so eine wunderschöne
Fundgrube im Grunde dort mal nachzusehen
und ein Punkt den man natürlich
überhaupt gar nicht vergessen darf sie
haben ja tatsächlich ein Loch im
Luftstrom der Amerikaner entdeckt denn
dass der Balance da so ungehindert
konnte musste jetzt erst im Nachgang
korrigiert werden durch eine Veränderung
der
radarauswertung der Amerika also von
daher waren sie dadurch aus auch pfiffig
in den letzten Ansatz also durchaus
bedenklich auch für die Amerikaner das
den Chinesen dass gelungen ist also sie
sagen eine weltweite Übung die für China
dann wiederum interessant ist sich das
anzuschauen und da eventuell
Informationen abzugreifen geht's denn da
mehr darum dass man abhört also
akustisch oder geht es mir darum dass
man Luft Aufklärung betreibt dass man
Fotos Aufnahmen macht wie wie ist das
einzuordnen
ja Fotos sind schon fast Geschäft von
gestern also die sind ja mittlerweile so
toll dass man selbst aus dem Weltraum
schon sehr gut fotografieren kann die
Masse heute und Kriegführung spielt sich
tatsächlich in dem nicht sichtbaren
Wellenbereichen ab und da geht's zum
Beispiel darum wie kann ich große
Mobilnetze Abhören es ist also unfassbar
was man über die Menschen individuell
auch aber auch in Gruppen erfahren kann
wie sie telefonieren von positiv
telefonieren mit welchen Inhalten sie
telefonieren das geht dann natürlich
auch auf Funksysteme oft geschützte
Funksysteme welche Ecken haben Sie
welche Merkmale haben sie damit ich
wiedererkenne wenn ich dieses Signal
sehe dann in sich vielleicht
amerikanische Spezialkräfte gerade in
meiner Nähe also solche Dinge spielen
dabei eine Rolle und das war gerade noch
mal ein Haken her Tele also was genau
hätten jetzt die chinesischen
Geheimdienste dabei erfahren können und
geht es da nur um militärische
Einrichtungen oder ist da auch die
Zivilbevölkerung der USA möglicherweise
betroffen gewesen in der hybriden
Kriegführung ist tatsächlich jeder
betroffen die amerikanische Losung schon
vor ein paar Jahren lautete und das
sieht man dann auch in den Investitionen
im Verteidigungsbudget empower the ins
also macht mir die Geheimdienste stark
und diese Geheimdienste sind eben nicht
James Bond also Personen das gibt es
auch weiterhin Geheimdienstler sondern
im Wesentlichen ist das eine
elektromagnetische Signal Aufklärung
also wie man hineinkommen kann in andere
Systeme wie ich mich auch ohne einen
USB-Stick in ein Netz in einem
Computernetzwerk hinein begeben kann
nicht dort Informationen fälschen kann
wie ich Drohnen entführen kann indem ich
ihn falsche Informationen suggeriere es
ist ein unglaubliches breites Biotop und
dass man einen einstößt und die Chinesen
das geht bei uns auch gerne unter sind
mittlerweile im künstliche Intelligenz
führend in der Welt bei Quanten
Physik macht man sich schon Gedanken
immer Amerikaner überhaupt noch abholen
können also die sind auch wirklich
Hightech und so ein großer Ballon der
schleppt jede Menge und die Amerikaner
werden schon mitbekommen haben in etwa
was da aktiv erforscht wird so dass sie
schon in der Luft wussten worum es sich
handelt und jetzt natürlich die
Bestandteile die technischen
Bestandteile suchen um noch mehr darüber
zu erfahren genau also er wird jetzt
versucht eben zu gucken was haben diese
Balance denn überhaupt an Material dabei
gehabt und wie kann das eventuell
ausgewertet werden aber wo wir gerade
beim Stichwort Ballon sind es verwundert
ja den Leinen vielleicht dann doch das
überhaupt noch Balance zum Einsatz
kommen das wirkt ja irgendwie ein
bisschen wie aus dem weiß ich nicht 19
oder 20 Jahrhundert und die Frage
schickt uns auch doki Cookie er vermutet
dass es bei einem Ballon darum geht dass
er tiefer fliegen kann der Vorteil
gegenüber Satelliten ist oder dass es
darum eben nicht geht sorry sondern der
Vorteil gegenüber Satelliten sei so
schreibt er das Balance viel länger über
der gleichen Stelle fliegen können Frage
an den Experten ist das der Vorteil wenn
deswegen die Balance noch eingesetzt
sie haben sozusagen sie denken eine
Lücke ab die ist da sonst nicht gibt
tatsächlich sind sie erst mal langsamer
zum zweiten sind sie auch sehr billig
wenn sie sich mal moderne Drohnen
anschauen die auch zu solchen
aufklärungsbecken benutzt werden die
Kosten 500 Millionen Euro oder US-Dollar
also sehr sehr teuer diese Balance sind
ja im Grunde Helium plus etwas Hülle
also sehr sehr preiswert sie bleiben
lange und sie sind auch nicht da dran
gerade in diesem elektromagnetischen
Spektrum ist Nähe von Bedeutung weil je
weiter ich weg bin umso viel mehr
Energie muss ich aufwenden um die
gleichen Erkenntnisse zusammen also von
daher ist es auch wichtig dass sie eben
Weltraum sind sondern dass sie viel
näher dran sind dann werden sie ihn
nicht entdeckt würden sie schnell
fliegen würde man sie eben erfassen aber
man sucht nach langsamen Dingen sucht
man nicht ne oder deswegen konnte der
Ballon auch da rein aber wenn ich Sie
richtig verstanden habe wird da jetzt
auch die Überwachung angepasst also das
jetzt eben auch nach langsameren
Objekten Ausschau gehalten wird
sie ist schon jetzt im Grunde angepasst
das heißt das hat der gefehlt aber
gerade von der Woche verkündet das hat
er jetzt bereits gemacht aber man wird
auch ordentlich investieren allein kann
er da und die USA wollen mehrere
Milliarden US-Dollar jetzt investieren
um solche Hütten künftig besser abdecken
zu können Dirk Otto fragt uns über
Youtube andererseits wenn man eine
abc-waffe ich ergänze jetzt einfach mal
oder eine andere gefährliche Waffe an so
einen Ballon hängt was würde dann
passieren ist das ein Sicherheitsrisiko
tendenziell nicht aber tatsächlich ich
habe die Frage heute schon mal gehabt
gibt es da gute Einsatzmöglichkeiten
generell sind diese Balance dadurch dass
sie sehr langsam sind dass sie an den
Wind an den Winden sozusagen gekoppelt
sind wesentlichen der Flugrichtung
leicht bekämpft war allerdings wenn man
daran jetzt smarte Waffen hängen würden
die in von dort fallen und gesteuert
werden und sich dann in Ziele hinein
locken dann ist das vielleicht ein ein
pfiffiger Gedanke weil man diese Ballons
ja von außerhalb des Hoheitsgebietes aus
dann aktivieren kann aber das müssen
natürlich alles gut geplant sein und
auch sehr sehr schwer dazu bekämpfen
sein also hier entsteht tatsächlich eine
neue Kategorie aber ich sehe diese nicht
im Bereich Waffen das scheint mir doch
zu weit ja wir wollen jetzt natürlich
auch keinen hier auf irgendwelche dummen
Gedanken bringen das liegt uns fern aber
es fällt ja schon auf dass ich diese
Vorfälle jetzt in den letzten zwei
Wochen enorm gehäuft haben eben mit
diesen vier Abschüssen dieser
verschiedenen Objekte warum was glauben
Sie jetzt diese Häufung gab es vorher
weniger Objekte oder geht es in den
Bereich den Sie gerade angesprochen
haben das ist jetzt erst richtig erfasst
wird und vorher gab es die auch schon
aber da hat keiner Notiz genommen
ja man hat da vorher nicht hingeguckt
also generell man hört das ja schon auch
an den Stellungnahmen generell geht man
nicht davon aus dass das nun alles
chinesische Produkte sind es gibt in
Amerika auch jede Menge Hobbyforscher
die Balance steigen lassen vielleicht
auch irgendwelche ritterpfosten die das
machen und natürlich nicht nur in den
USA also von daher fliegt da oben viel
rum was da nicht hingehört was wir aber
nicht gesehen haben weil wir bedrohlich
eigentlich immer gucken auf Radar
Querschnitt auf Geschwindigkeit auf Höhe
und da hatten wir uns auf belong Ballon
gedrungen auch ballonspionage nicht
eingerichtet das wird jetzt mit
Sicherheit anders werden Stefan fragt
uns über Youtube warum haben die anderen
Objekte solche komische Formen also da
war ja von zylinderförmigen Objekten die
Rede in insgesamt waren die drei
späteren Objekte deutlich kleiner als
der erste Ballon der ja so wie drei
Busse etwa groß gewesen sein soll die
anderen kleiner wie gesagt auch mit
merkwürdigen Formen kann man sich darauf
schon irgendeinen reinmachen
bislang nicht und das wird ja auch
heruntergespielt also ich denke mal
diese kleineren Objekte werden nicht so
viel Aufmerksamkeit verdienen
tatsächlich war ja interessanter das
zeitgleich zu diesem ersten großen
Ballon auch in Mittelamerika ein Ballon
gesichtet wurde und auch angeblich in
Europa also von daher ist das sicherlich
der Anschlag der Chinesen gewesen also
hier Spionage mäßig mal richtig fett zu
schöpfen die kleineren Balance sehe ich
bislang eben als üblicher wie soll ich
mal sagen irrflieger die dadurch die
Gegend fliegen was sie nicht sollten so
ähnlich wie du um die in der Nähe des
Flugplatzes fliegen obwohl sie nicht
sollten ja aber sie sprechen jetzt
gerade den auch größeren Ballon über
Mittelamerika an wie muss man sich das
vorstellen das ist ja kein Zufall also
ist das irgendwie Teil eines größeren
Spionageprogramm kann man davon einer
Ballon Flotte da sprechen die die Länder
so in alle Hände Himmelsrichtungen
schicken oder wie ist das ja gezielt
diese Jetstreams die hier oben haben
ganz großen Höhen sind die sind ja
relativ berechenbar und wie man jetzt
nun von diesem Ballon über Nordamerika
aus der Beobachtung weiß war der auch
mit Steuerungseinrichtungen verbunden so
dass er in diesen Jetstreams ein
bisschen nach links und rechts
navigieren konnte und vor allen Dingen
auch die Fahrt verzögern konnte so dass
er länger über Bereiche braucht also ich
denke das war gezielt auf diese Woche
dieses global information
Experiments der Amerikaner angelegt wo
man einfach sagte hier haben wir die
große Chance die Amerikaner mal bei
einer Neuerung richtig auszuforschen und
deswegen hat das natürlich auch Amerika
besonders geärgert gerade noch mal die
Nachfrage auch von einem unserer
Zuschauer dieses global domination
Experiment wie sie gerade noch mal
zitiert haben vielleicht können Sie dazu
doch noch mal zwei drei Sätze sagen
damit alle das verstehen also worum ging
es da was haben die USA da genau
getestet
wenn ich mal ganz weit zurück schaue
früher war es so dass zwischen einem
Soldaten und seinem großen Befehlshaber
drei Tage Zeitunterschied lagen das
heißt der der Befehlshaber musste immer
viel viel später erst was los ist die
Kunst in der Kriegführung ist heute fast
in Echtzeit genau zu wissen wer was wann
wo macht und derjenige der das besser
beherrscht kann bessere Entscheidungen
treffen und schnellere Entscheidung
treffen darauf ist die Kriegführung der
Amerikaner ausgerichtet und genauso ist
natürlich damit die Krieg Führung der
Chinesen ausgerichtet dieses ist jetzt
aber in einem Verbund der nicht mehr nur
auf Streitkräfte schaut sondern im
Grunde auch auf wirtschaftliche
Tätigkeiten schaut und damit kommen
jetzt Cyberattacken mit nein damit
kommen kritische Infrastruktur mit
hinein und auch die befrucht
Beeinflussung von gezielte Beeinflussung
von Entscheidungsträgern das ist
sozusagen das Paket und das wurde eben
in dieser Woche global information
Experiment geprobt und deswegen war das
auch so spannend für Kinder da
mitzuhören okay gleichzeitig
gleichzeitig werfen die Chinesen den
usa-werten ins angesprochen ihrerseits
ja auch Spionage vor also mehr als 10
Balance sein im letzten Jahr über den
chinesischen Luftraum gefahren die USA
widersprechen wie bewerten Sie diese
Situation ich glaube in dem Fall haben
die USA recht also auch wenn das
us-balance gewesen sein mögen wenn die
nicht Nachrichten in sich sein die
Amerikaner sind einfach von ihrer
Spezifizierung Weltraum Drohnen alle
möglichen fernreichen elektronischen
Abhören Möglichkeiten so Hightech
ausgerichtet dass ihm der Ballon nicht
in den Sinn gekommen wäre also mir
erscheint das vollkommen abwegig weil
sie einfach so viele andere
Möglichkeiten haben und umgekehrt ist
tatsächlich das sehen wir häufiger diese
andere Kultur aus der Asien im Grunde
herauskommen sonst sie sozusagen geprägt
eine Kultur die den Wege hat die dir so
nicht haben das war sehr klug den Ballon
zu nehmen weil wir am besten an diese
Option nicht gedacht haben ja könnte man
das ist vielleicht auch psychologisch
interessant darin auch noch mal eben
eine bewusste Provokation Seiten Chinas
sehen also mehr so ein psychologischer
Test auch wie gehen die USA überhaupt
mit dieser Situation um was machen die
mit dem Ballon schießen die drauf
schießen die nicht drauf er ist das für
China auch interessant
ich sehe da jetzt keine
provokationsabsicht in diesem Moment
darum China geht es im Augenblick
schlechter ökonomisch als es das geplant
hatte und China ist ein sehr Planungs
dominiertes Land also sie suchen jetzt
Wege ihre ökonomische Situation deutlich
zu verbessern dazu sind Gespräche mit
Amerika von bedeuten und der
amerikanische Außenminister wollte ja
nach China fliegen das wollte China
nicht torbidieren beide Regierung haben
eigentlich ein großes Interesse die
derzeitigen Spannung wieder ein bisschen
herunterzubringen und die gegenseitige
Prosperität wieder ein bisschen
hochzufahren also von daher rechne ich
nicht mit einer chinesischen Absicht in
diesem Fall Jens andere Check wir
sprechen gleich noch mal über das
Spannungsverhältnis Jens anderer Check
fragt uns über Youtube woher weiß man
dass der Ballon aus China kam stand da
etwa made in China drauf oder was
inzwischen haben die Chinesen ist ja
selber eingeräumt aber es war relativ
schnell klar dass der aus China kommen
würde
ja sie hatten auch tatsächlich relativ
rasch um Entschuldigung gebeten
außerordentlich das macht China kaum das
ist also ein großer Gesichtsverlust auch
das zeigt schon das China nicht
provozieren wollte nein man merkt das an
den Technologien die verwendet werden
weil natürlich beide Seiten einander
immer ausspähen was kann der andere was
macht er und bei den Sensoren die an
Bord so eines Balance oder auch andere
von Flugzeugen oder anderen Mitteln sind
da gibt es passive von denen merkt man
nichts also sie nehmen nur Dinge auf
aber es gibt auch aktive die suchen nach
Dingen und diese suchen haben bestimmte
Signaturen die erkennt man dass wir
unsere Handschrift oder unsere
Unterschrift die kann man erkennen und
daran kann man eben erkennen dass es
eben etwas was aus Nordkorea kommt oder
was aus Iran kommt oder eben etwas was
aus China kommt also von daher haben sie
aus diesen aktiven Sensoren das
herauslesen können ja nehmen wir gerade
auch schon angesprochen das
Spannungsverhältnisse auf zwischen den
beiden Nationen welche Rolle spielt denn
z.B auch der Konflikt um Taiwan in
diesem Zusammenhang China begreift ja
den Inselstaat als eigenes Territorium
droht immer mal wieder mit einer
Invasion die USA wollen das verhindern
was spielt das für eine Rolle
das spielt natürlich eine
große Rolle denn
die Kita meint es ja ernst mit der
Wiedervereinigung allerdings denkt China
eben in anderen Zeitstrecken als der
Westen also die können auch in 30 oder
50 Jahren noch die Vereinigung anstreben
und das langsam machen und nutzen dazu
dann eben auch Korruptionen und
wirtschaftliche Tätigkeit miteinander um
das aufzuweichen alle möglichen anderen
Möglichkeiten natürlich auch militärisch
militärische Macht die USA in der
gegenwärtigen weltpolitischen
Auseinandersetzung mit China wer
bestimmt eigentlich die Dinge in dieser
Welt in China hinterfragt natürlich z.B
sind ist das Rechtssystem in der Welt so
in Ordnung wie es ist bevorzugtes nicht
die besten sind Wirtschaftssysteme so in
Ordnung vollzogen die wichtigsten also
hier gibt es eine große
Auseinandersetzung der beiden China und
USA werden bestimmt hat künftiges sagen
in der Welt und da machen die USA im
Augenblick die Muskel groß auch gerade
um Taiwan und das ist natürlich ein
Problem dass der Entspannung die beide
Nationen eigentlich miteinander im Auge
haben entgegen steht und das wird jetzt
noch durch das innenpolitische Spiel in
Amerika befördert weil die Republikaner
eigentlich dem amerikanischen
Präsidenten sagen wollen du bist schwach
du kannst nichts entscheiden du traust
dich noch nicht mal ein Ballon
abzuschießen und so wird natürlich das
auch innenpolitisch amerikanisch
befördert also das ist ein das ist ein
problematische Situation letzte Frage
wir haben vorhin von unserer Kollegin
aus Washington gehört dass da durchaus
eine Besorgnis in den USA vorhanden ist
für vibrisand halten sie die aktuelle
Lage und wie groß schätzen sie das
Eskalation sozusagen Potential ein also
es stehen wir da jetzt wirklich an der
Schwelle zu einer weiteren Eskalation
denn wenn man jetzt noch mal drauf
schaut natürlich die beiden Supermächte
sind systemische Rivalen andererseits
eben auch wichtige gegenseitige
Handelspartner also wie wird sich das
entwickeln
ich bin also eigentlich nicht besorgt
muss ich sagen aus grundsätzlichen
Überlegungen eben wie gesagt beide
Nationen großen Werk darauf legen jetzt
wirtschaftlich die Situation nach Corona
und den auch Ukraine Verwerfungen zu
bekommen es gibt ja auch den Gedanken
China stärker ins Spiel zu bringen bei
dem mit Blick auf eine Ukraine Lösung
eine eine friedliche Reinigung des
ukrades Konflikts und auch da gucken die
Amerikaner auf das chinesische Potential
ich nehme jetzt mal ein Stimmungsbild
dass ich am Sonntag gewonnen habe ich
kam da war da noch in New York davon der
chinesische Neujahrstag statt mit einer
riesigen Parade und Schumer der
mehrheitsführer im amerikanischen Senat
spaziert in der fröhlich zwischen
chinesischen amerikanischen Platten und
alle Leute freut mich ich sag mal ich
sehe da keine großen Krise ja dann
nehmen wir das mal als gutes oben vielen
Dank für das Gespräch das war der
Militärexperte und Oberst AIDA Ralf
Thiele danke schön und einen schönen
Abend sehr gerne
ja und auch von euch natürlich ein
großes Dankeschön für die fragen
Kommentare gab es heute nicht aber
immerhin einige Fragen die war dran
nehmen durften wir wünschen euch
natürlich noch einen schönen Abend und
sagen bis zum nächsten mal Danke und auf
Wiedersehen ciao ciao